We're on problem 24.
Use the solution procedure below
to answer the question
that follows.
Which of the following is a
major flaw in the procedure
shown above?
So let's look for some flaws.
So the way I always like to do
it is just think about how I
would have done it.
So if I started with minus 3x
plus 25 is equal to 4, the
first thing I would do is
subtract 25 from both sides of
the equation.
So I would take a minus 25 from
the left-hand side, and
then a minus 25 from the
right-hand side.
And it looks like that's what
the person did-- took a minus
25 there and they took a minus
the 25, just like that.
And then he said, OK,
well that's the same
thing as minus 21.
So then you would get minus 3x,
on the left-hand side, is
equal to minus 21.
I have a sense that I already
know what the major flaw is.
He's doing two steps, and he's
not writing a nice clean
equality, and he's trying
to skip steps.
And my guess is that he's
going to get confused.
So then you end up with
minus 3x on the
left-hand side, right?
Because these cancel out.
Minus 3x is equal to minus 21.
So you get that.
So you get that right there.
So you get minus 3x is equal
to minus 21, and then you
divide both sides by minus 3,
and you get x is equal to 7.
So the guy got the right answer,
however he or she may
have done it.
But this is a little confusing,
because then
divides by 3, but you know, this
divide by minus 3, which
you do have to do, you
have to do to both
sides of this equation.
I just don't see where
he or she did it.
Maybe, you know, somehow
they just
divided by minus 3 randomly.
I don't know why.
They didn't really understand
the notion of
inequality on an equation.
You have to do the same
thing to both
sides of this equation.
So let's see what
the choices are.
The concept of the opposite
number is confused with
subtraction.
No, not really.
The equal sign is used to
connect expressions
that are not equal.
That sounds about right, because
this expression, that
expression, and this
are equal.
We got minus 3x plus 25, minus
25, which is just minus 3x.
That does indeed equal 4
minus 25 or minus 21.
But that does not equal minus
21 divided by minus 3.
So this looks like my answer.
Let's look at the
other choices.
The solution contains
an error in the
arithmetic of signed numbers.
No, the solution is
arithmetically correct.
D, the order of operations
between subtraction and
division is reversed.
I really don't see that.
So, my choice would be B.
They don't-- the equal sign--
this, right here, does not
equal this, right over there.
Next problem.
25.
Use the diagram below
to answer the
question that follows.
So let's see, they're extending
by 1 in each direction.
They're kind of creating
this triangle.
If the pattern continues, how
many more small squares are in
figure 100 than are
in figure 99?
So let's think, every time we
increment it, how may squares
are we adding?
When we go from 1 to 2,
how many did we add?
We added 1, 2 squares.
When we went from 2 to 3,
how many did we add?
We added 1, 2, 3 squares.
When we went from 3 to 4,
how many did we add?
We added 1, 2, 3, 4 squares.
Those are the 4 that are
kind of layered over
the 3, right there.
So when you go from
99 to 100, we're
going to add 100 squares.
We're going to add
100 squares.
When we go from n to n plus 1,
we're adding n plus 1 squares.
So you go from 99 to 100,
you add 100 squares.
Or there are 100 more squares
in the 100 figure
than in the 99 figure.
Next problem.
All right.
Problem 26.
Use the table below to answer
the question that follows.
We have a x-axis, and then
we have a y-axis.
And what do they
want us to do?
Each number in the table above
represents a value of w that
is determined by the values
of integers x and y.
For example, when x equals 2, y
equals 1, w is equal to 21.
If the pattern continues, what
is the value of w when x is
equal to 20, and y
is equal to 8?
So let's see if we can get
a sense of what w is.
So w, if you remember your
functions, w is a function
of-- I can write it
like that-- is a
function of x and y.
That might confuse you.
It may or may not.
We just have to figure out
what this function is.
So if you look at this pattern
every time we look here, we
go-- so this is 0 to 8.
And then we go from 8 to 16.
So, this is, we're adding 8
every time we go to the right.
We're adding 8, right?
It looks like we are.
And then as we go up,
what are we doing?
So this is plus 8.
So for example, this right
here is 4 times 8.
This is 3 times 8.
So it looks like w is
equal to 8 times x.
But then as you go
up, what happens?
As you go up, we're adding
5 every time.
Is that throughout
the whole table?
Yeah, sure.
37 plus 5 is 42.
We add 5 every time.
And we start here,
just 8 times x.
And then when y is 0, and then
we add 1 times 5, 2 times 5.
Looks like it's 8x plus 5y.
That's what w is.
Right?
And let's verify it.
We pick the point 3, 2, so that
would be w is equal to 8
times 3, plus 5 times 2.
So w is equal to 24 plus 10 is
equal to 34, which is, indeed,
what it equals.
So we found our function
of x and y.
And what are they asking?
If the pattern continues, what
is the value when x is equal
to 20 and y is equal to 8?
Well, in that situation, w is
equal to 8 times x, which is
20, plus 5 times y, which is 8,
which is equal to 160 plus
40, which is equal to 200.
And that is choice B.
Next problem.
Problem 27.
The function r of x gives the
remainder when a whole number
x is divided by 10.
Which of the following graphs
represents r of x?
So when you take something on
the x-axis and divide it by
10, r of x should be
its remainder.
So we take 5 divided by 10.
The remainder is 5.
So we should plot out to
be a 5 right there.
When you take 10 divided by 10,
your answer is-- well, the
answer is 1, and your
remainder is 0.
So that looks right.
And then 15, the
remainder is 5.
So those look right.
Let's see, when you plot, when
you have 1, 1 divided by 5, 1
divided by-- sorry-- 1 divided
by 10, the remainder is 1.
That looks right.
This graph A looks
pretty good.
If you take, you know,
20 divided by 10, the
remainder is 0.
If you take 30 divided by
10, the remainder is 0.
If you take 29 divided
by 10, the
remainder is 9, right there.
19 divided by 10, the
remainder is 9.
9 divided by 10, the
This one looks pretty good.
Let's see what the
other ones do.
So here, let's see, when I take
10 divided by 10, the
remainder should be 0.
This should be a 0 right here,
but they have it the
remainder being 10.
So this is wrong, right
off the bat.
And then here, the remainder
when a whole number x is
divided by-- this is a whole
number, right, whole number x.
Here, they're doing it for
essentially all of the real
numbers, right?
This would be true if they
said any real number, but
they're including fractions,
because they're filling in the
gaps right here.
So C and D are not dealing
with whole numbers.
So our answer is definitely A.